monsieur voyez les ailes du maine comme
beaucoup d'ailleurs au club offre aux
personnes qui le désirent des baptêmes
de l'air mais vous en plus vous offrez
une visite commentée de la ville du mans
quand l'avion alors qu'est ce qui a
motivé cette initiative
eh bien je pense qu'il est donc toutes
les personnes qui ont un baptême de
l'air puisse apprécier en même temps le
site qui se déroule sous leurs yeux et
par conséquent bien comprendre la
géographie de la ville ainsi que ses
richesses en sites monuments et autres
établissements combien de temps dure
cette visite un peu moins d'un quart
d'heure
et je crois que c'est accessible à tous
oui bien sûr puisque un baptême de l'air
coût de 20 francs par personne et je
vois que vous avez aussi d'autres
projets disons plus loin du main oui il
est possible à la demande et les
personnes d'effectuer par exemple une
visite des châteaux de la loire
on peut d'une en 20 minutes sur relay le
château du lude
on peut ensuite s'en aller sur les
châteaux de la loire tours amboise
chenonceau et même plus loin au gré de
la personne on va aller vers le nom de
la ville en se dirigeant vers la
cathédrale du mans oui on l'aperçoit
données regarder madame la cathédrale du
mans la wii
juste à côté tout le vieux mans on
distingue même en ce moment consiste
avec 20 de l'enceinte gallo-romaine
oui maintenant on va filer un peu vers
l'ouest et on arrive place de la
république
la nouvelle place qu'on est en train de
faire qui peut se terminer c'est un une
plaque de béton en fait vers 17 ou gris
oui voilà
maintenant on s'en retourne vers le
terrain et on va survoler le circuit des
24 heures du mans
on va surtout voir le circuit bugatti
qui est beaucoup plus utile on voit tous
ces virages
voilà ici oui madame c'est la première
fois que vous voulez vous de prendre vos
thèmes de l'air vous l'avez produit du
mans ça vous intéresser le monde
je ne pensais pas tellement bien passé
aussi riche que la visite était
commentée
j'ai trouvé que c'était très intéressant
beaucoup plus intéressant qu'un simple
baptême de l'air c'est la première fois
que je venais au dessus du mans était la
première fois vous faisait une visite
commentée
c'est la première fois aussi d'ailleurs
que je le vois faire les autres aéroclub
que je connais déjà n'organisait pas de
visites commentées lui existent et les
baptêmes de l'air
parce que l'on trouve dans tous les
héros claude mais une visite commentée
de la ville c'est la première fois que
je le vois faire cela vous intéresser
c'est intéressant oui ça permet de voir
la ville sous un autre aspect ça permet
de mesurer l'étendue de la ville ça
permet en particulier au monde se rende
compte de l'étendue du circuit on situe
mieux la ville de dans son contexte
géographique donc à votre avis une
initiative qui devrait s'étendre
je pense oui d'ailleurs il n'y a aucune
difficulté à l'étendre à tous les héros
club il suffit de connaître un petit peu
le passé de la ville de pouvoir en
parler
c'est tout ça me paraît assez facile à
faire